what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
news about Loki season two a show that a
lot of fans are really really looking
forward to if you look at a bunch of
different people's rankings for the MCU
Disney Plus shows Loki is typically at
the very top either first second or
third with it being first a lot it is
personally my favorite Marvel Disney
Plus show to date one division is a very
tight second but Loki remains at the top
and not to mention Loki season 2 is
going to be incredibly important moving
forward in the MCU because of Kang now
some projects in Phase 4 have not all
connected to King the Conqueror but we
already know that Loki season 2 is going
to involve Kang a lot so not only will
this movie directly affect the MCU as a
whole but it'll directly affect what
happens in Avengers the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars so a pretty big
upcoming show the unfortunate news is it
may be getting delayed so we're gonna
talk about when to exactly expect Loki
season 2 in this video as well as go
over some new Daredevil Born Again news
and Deadpool 3 news as well and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe if you want to stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU now if
you have been following the channel you
might have heard recently that the
entire Phase 5 and phase six slate might
actually all be getting pushed back
these reports are coming from some
insiders in the industry but they're
also coming directly from Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige and Disney CEO Bob
Iger both of them recently have come out
and basically announced that Marvel
Studios is going to be sort of shifting
their focus focusing more on quality now
over quantity and when asked if that
meant fewer projects coming out per year
Kevin feige said yes now as far as we're
concerned nothing is being canceled
they're not going to cancel any projects
that are upcoming for the MCU and Phase
5 or phase six or at least none that
they've announced so far we obviously
haven't gotten all of phase six yet so
what this means is most likely
everything is simply going to be pushed
back and it looks like today we are
seeing our first signs of that with Loki
getting pushed back unfortunately now
when Marvel Studios announced Phase 5
they listed Loki for summer of 2023 so
not even an exact release date but a
good time frame now we originally
expected a July 12th or August 30th
release date these dates were decided
after looking at the other Disney Plus
shows that Disney has coming out during
the summer also keep in mind secret
Invasion has to come out before Loki
season 2. at least that's what Marvel
Studios has planned we've gotten a full
trailer for secret Invasion already and
only kind of teasers for Loki season 2.
so that does still seem to be Marvel
studios's plan release secret Invasion
before Loki let's keep in mind right now
Disney has the Mandalorian season 3 out
which means secret Invasion will most
likely air around May 10th which means
it should end around June 14th then you
have to keep in mind that the Ahsoka
series is coming out however it is most
likely coming out after Loki season 2.
so before that put us at a July 12th or
an August 30th release date depending on
when Ahsoka airs however recently Marvel
and Disney have changed what they have
previously said for the release date of
Loki whereas before it said summer of
2023 if you look on Disney plus now at
the release date for Loki season 2. it
simply says coming soon and
unfortunately like I mentioned since we
do have the Mandalorian season 3 and
secret Invasion to get through first
that means it's most likely not coming
sooner than its original intended date
but most likely much later now
unfortunately we've had some reports
before that stated that Marvel Studios
is most likely only releasing two Disney
Plus shows this year secret Invasion and
Loki and I think that now more than ever
after this new report is definitely
going to be true I don't see them
releasing any more than secret Invasion
and Loki I think they are pushing
everything back and with Loki being
pushed back a little bit it definitely
is going to shift the entire Phase 5 and
6 slate but I still do believe Loki
season 2 is coming this year it is most
likely coming in September it could
simply just be a late summer debut now
but this will most likely debut the
other Disney plus series that Marvel
Studios has coming out like what if
season 2 The Echo series X-Men 97 the
Animated Series ironheart Agatha coven
of chaos Daredevil born again and
Spider-Man freshman year the Animated
Series I'm assuming that Marvel Studios
is going to give us an update about
something relatively soon there are some
cons coming up where Marvel Studios is
most likely going to attend and they'll
most likely make an announcement plus
not to mention we haven't really heard
anything about the Fantastic Four
recently and people are looking at
Marvel Studios to make an announcement
it doesn't mean that they will however
Marvel knows that we're all waiting for
that in previous recent reports indicate
that they're pretty close at picking who
they want to be their Fantastic Four so
if they get their cast relative soon
hopefully we can get an announcement
about that as well with an updated
release schedule so hopefully we can get
an update about kind of the entire MCU
really soon including Deadpool 3 which
is a project that a lot of people are
really excited about and recently Hugh
Jackman has shared some photos and
videos of him getting in Wolverine shape
he shared this video to Instagram with
the caption I'm hashtag becoming
Wolverine again and in this video he
actually makes a reference to one of
Ryan reynolds's latest movies spirited
where he says good afternoon which in
the movie is kind of a joke where they
explain that in the olden days it kind
of meant Fu so while Hugh Jackman is
doing this excruciating workout he says
good afternoon jokingly basically
meaning Fu for making me do this but he
has to get back in Wolverine shape thank
you
good afternoon
one more
[Music]
now to end with some good news although
we are seemingly getting some delays
here from Marvel Studios and again that
is a good thing because Marvel Studios
is going to focus on giving us better
quality projects rather than just a
bunch of okay Disney Plus shows but to
end it on a really good note we have our
first behind the scenes photo of Matt
Murdock AKA Daredevil Charlie Cox
returning to the set to film or
Daredevil Born Again filming and
production has officially begun Twitter
user Danny gone 16 posted a photo of
himself alongside Charlie Cox on the set
of Daredevil Born Again giving us our
first look at Charlie Cox back as Matt
Murdock for his own show because he
already appeared on Shield but for his
own show and the filming has officially
begun now two kind of three things that
you need to know about Daredevil born
again is one it is confirmed that John
Bernthal is returning as The Punisher
when news got out about this he himself
even can confirmed that he is returning
by posting him as the Punisher on
Instagram so that is huge there is also
a rumor that Kristen Ritter is going to
be returning as well and appearing on
the show but I'll Loop that in with the
first thing the second thing that you
need to know is that Vanessa Fisk has
been recast for this show and Marvel
Studios has cast cedrine Holt to play
Vanessa Fisk the wife of Wilson Fisk AKA
Kingpin who of course is going to be one
of the major characters in the show and
the villain of course and the last thing
that you need to know and this kind of
goes for all other MCU projects is that
Marvel Studios is cracking down on leaks
so unfortunately we may not get as many
behind the scenes photos that we used to
get now paparazzi's snapping set photos
aren't illegal but they still might be
cracking down on who exactly can show
them online so we might not get as much
behind the scene photos but I'm sure
we're still going to get a few but of
course if anything happens on set and
the word gets out about it we'll be sure
to do videos on it so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news please don't
forget to like the video and of course
leave us your thoughts about all of this
news in the comments down below you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf